انهيار شركه اف تي اكس ثاني اكبر من الصا
لتداول العملات المشفره هز السوق المهزوجه
بالاساس وطرح اسئله كبيره هو هي حتى الان
من دون اجابات لكن الامور قد تتغير مع
اعلان اعضاء في لجنه الخدمات الماليه في
مجلس النواب الامريكي نيتهم عقد اجتماع
الشهر المقبل للتحقيق في انهيار ثاني اكبر
منصه لتبادل العملات المشفره في العالم
اللجنه قالت
صحيفه وسط جورنال انها تتوقع الاستماع
لافادات مؤسس المنصه سام بانك مان برايد
وكذلك الى شركه التجاريه على سي وايضا من
الاكبر والمنافسه الاولى باينس انهيار اف
تي اكس الحق ضرارا جسيما باكثر من مليون
مستخدم كثيرون منهم كانوا اشخاصا عاديين
استثمر مدخراتهم المكتسبه بشق الانفس في
المنصه
[موسيقى]
تقدمت افتي اكس بطلب الحمايه من الافلاس
في الحادي عشر من نوفمبر الجاري
من منصب الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه يعني
وقتا طويلا سيمضي قبل ان يتمكن عملاء
ودائن والشركه من استرداد اموالهم هذا
بانهيار اف تي اكس امر يسلط الضوء على
مستقبل صناعه العملات
ان اموالهم محفوظه بامان لكن المنصه
مررتها على ما يبدو لاستخدامها في
المضاربه
الصحيفه استغربت موقفه كل من لجنه الاوراق
الماليه والبورسات الامريكيه ولجنه تداول
السلعه الاجيله وهم اللتان لم تفعل شيئا
يذكر حتى الان على الاقل
قبل انهيار افتي اكس وضع المؤسس الملايين
في جهود الوقايه من الاوبئه وسامحت له
ثوره الانفاق على جماعه الضغط والمساهمات
في الحملات وخبراء الاتصالات السياسيه
بالوصول الى اروقه السلطه وتامين لقاءات
مع رئيسه مجلس النواب الديمقراطيه نانسي
بيلوسي و زعيم الاقل في مجلس الشيوخ نجمه
كامل اليوم توقفت معظم جهود باكمان فرايد
مع اخيه غابي ايضا الذي يعمل في الكونجرس
في دعم قطاع الصحه العامه ما سيؤثر سلبا
على التقدم في هذا المجال الحياوي لقد
كانت تبرعات الشاب ثري سابقا سخيه بما
يكفي لسد العوز قال سام باتمان برايد
سابقا امام لجنه كورونا ان الشيء الذي
يقلقه اكثر هو جائه اكثر
لكن الجائحه التي ضربت شركته قضت على
ملياراته ال16
مليارا لتكون بالنسبه اليها على الاقل
اقصى من كوفد الذي عرفناه والذي يمكن ان
نعرفه لاحقا
[موسيقى]